le compte à rebours se poursuit plus que
18 mois maintenant
avant le retrait progressif des
microbilles de nos produits de beauté et
de nettoyage et ainsi de nos océans
en fait très près de nous dans les eaux
du fleuve saint laurent à certains
endroits les chercheurs ont trouvé plus
d'un millier de microbilles par litre
d'eau il s'agit ici d'une proportion
largement supérieures à celles des
secteurs les plus contaminés ont montré
beaucoup plus que ce que je m'attends
avec mes treize mille têtes des pins
devant vous sur une table normal qui
plus qu'un mètre carré je m'imagine ce
qui est encore plus petit donc c'est
énorme les quantités télé par chambaud
et biologistes de l'institut des
sciences de la mer de rimouski il est
rapide et c'est encore mais ce qu'on
connaît c'est que le premier un pacs et
les organismes marins
un peu à l'image du ver de terre on
prend des particules de la surface du
sédiment et les enfouir plus
profondément premier impact les
particules vont être répartis beaucoup
plus profondément dans les sédiments
compense deuxième impact les organismes
vont donc les ingérer où ils peuvent pas
savoir cesser mangeable ou non et on
s'aperçoit que les organismes un gérant
du plastique ont des taux de croissance
et ses moindres bien entendu c'est et
aucune énergie à consommer une
particules de plastique
et si au moins d'énergie mais
nécessairement ils vont moins m
d'énergie à la reproduction aussi dans
les océans avec un effet complet sur la
chaîne alimentaire et on s'est aperçu
que toutes ces micro billes collecte en
même temps des contaminants c'est que
les microparticules vont servir un peu
de jackass eu du nez main aux
contaminants qui peuvent être ingérée
par les organismes et encore une fois
s'ils sont ingérés et je prends l'image
d'un ver marin qui se fait consommer par
un poisson éventuellement sans revenir
sur la table et on va donc consommer des
particules de plastique ou indirectement
ni contaminants qu'elles renferment
l'état d'illinois lui qui le premier est
intervenu à légiférer pour protéger ces
cours d'eau est elle vraiment c'était
catégorique on est fin des terres du
crayon sur son territoire de la table
car ayant mis de l'avant des produits
contenant des microbes et en ontario la
députée provinciale marie-france allende
a tenté en 2015 sans succès de proposer
un projet de loi qui bannirait
l'utilisation des microbes
dans la province de l'ontario au fil des
années en 2009 connus la première équipe
du mérite pour une bonté des chercheurs
d'os clean l'ont démontré les effets
toxiques des microbes et de classique
dans nos eaux et en plus de 100 en 2013
nation biographie a publié un article
donc à ce moment alors sur l'effet des
microbilles dans les grands lacs
d'amérique du nord et l'est dans cette
partie peut devenir suffisamment élevé
pour que des bus cassés qu'elle soit
colonisé par des bactéries par des
plantes etc
sa forme en fait le début son voeu d'un
écosystème bizarre louis fortier et
directeur en biologie et en
océanographie à l'université laval dans
la ville du québec
il est spécialiste des poissons et des
plancton marin et directeur scientifique
d'arcticnet et à sang alors que l'écumé
avait créé un mécanisme de sortir des
rivières pour l'empêcher d'atteindre
l'océan soit c'est des possibilités mais
ça représente qu'une petite partie de la
solution
parce que déjà on a hypothéqué nos
océans en y déversant depuis la fin de
la guerre ont produit c'est après la
deuxième grande guerre commence à
produire industriellement des classes
existe des projets à l'heure actuelle
pour développer des technologies pour
ramasser ses plaies et ça semble assez
prometteur
il ya un projet qui s'appelle aux
chaînes climat c'est à dire de nettoyage
de l'océan où on a imaginé déployés dans
l'océan des barrières de l'attendre
récupérer ce plastique là et qui semble
enfin au moins ce que les promoteurs en
montre là ça semble assez prometteur
donc à barrière récolte la surface il ya
plusieurs inconvénients qui sont
soupçonnés dont on pense que ça pourrait
récolter remettant le plein temps il
faut j'ai plus de problèmes que de
solutions à mon avis c'est un faux seins
faux inquiétudes parce que le plancton
ce n'est peut-être et d'étain donc même
sur lui-même à partir même temps qu'on
élimine de plastique en quelques heures
pour le phytoplancton et en quelques
jours pour le zooplancton ses 6,1 des
organismes devront se redévelopper il
réapparaît donc c'est à mon avis c'est
pas un problème selon des données du
programme des nations unies pour
l'environnement les microbilles
constituerait plus de 80% de tous les
débris que l'on retrouve dans les vastes
étendues d'eau de la planète
le scénographe françois galgani
responsable du projet environnement à
l'institut français de recherche pour
l'exploitation de la mer explique on
utilise des granulés industriels qui
font un ou deux millimètres d'épaisseur
l'industrie pour fabriquer les objets
plastiques elle trans et granulés lé
chauffe ça donne cette espèce de liquide
plastique auquel on va donner une forme
à ce moment là on va arriver à voir des
objets et donc il ya tout un problème
lié à l'utilisation de ces granulés
industrielle si vous voulez et ça
représente en mer à cause des accidents
ou des problèmes de transport dans les
usines c'est à dire qu'on en voit ça
dans les eaux de ruissellement et autres
traits dans les rivières et samia la mer
disons qu'on arrive à peu près à 10% de
micro plastiques en mer qui sont
directement issus de l'industrie sans
avoir été utilisé pour la fabrication de
divers objets et puis après donc ces
microplastiques dans les cosmétiques et
là par contre dans la réalité ce sont
des quantités qui sont assez faibles par
rapport si vous voulez à l'ampleur du
problème et aux apports diffus ou de
produits industriels
un reportage de radio canada
international